statt 85 jahren einfach mal 150 jahre
alt werden
wer träumt davon nicht und wir berichten
immer mal wieder darüber den gentechnik
und medizin sind dabei diesen alten
menschheitstraum schon bald real werden
zu lassen
doch wie weit ist die forschung was
bieten sich und dadurch für vorteile und
würde unsere erde überhaupt mit all den
nebenwirkungen zurechtkommen herzlich
willkommen bei pixum science fiction
ja ihr habt euch dieses thema bei
whatsapp gewünscht wird damit dabei sein
könnte und hiermit bestimmt was läuft
das erfahrt ihr am ende des videos das
gilt übrigens auch mit anderen
messengern ein ewiges leben
das ist wohl der traum der meisten
menschen eine pille gegen das altern
oder gleich direkt gegen den tod das
wäre ja wohl was aber erfunden hat das
noch niemand und vielen von uns reicht
es nicht dass sich die lebenserwartung
seit 1840 verdoppelt hat und sie alle
vier jahre um ein weiteres jahr an
steigt und so tüfteln nicht nur medizin
und gentechnik hartnäckig daran die
lebensspanne von uns menschen um das
zwei bis dreifache aus zu denen auch
googles schwesterfirma kaliko
beispielsweise geht gegen das alter vor
eines der größten geheimnisse des lebens
wie es auf der offiziellen website heißt
menschen sollen durch die
fortschrittlichen technologien von
kaliko schon bald gesünder und länger
leben können was die forschungsteams
hier genau machen was ist nicht so
wirklich bekannt fest steht dass es
forschungsallianzen zu pharmaunternehmen
gibt und man sich wohl auf
alterskrankheiten wie krebs diabetes
demenz und herz kreislauf erkrankungen
konzentriert und ähnlich wie
mittlerweile im gesamten silicon valley
wird hier wohl die devise sein es gibt
nichts was datenverarbeitung und
technologie nicht können und mit hilfe
der daten sammele reihe von
medizinischen und genetischen daten
könnte die lebensverlängerung
tatsächlich eines tages wirklichkeit
werden wir haben hier bei pixum sich
schon mehrmals darüber berichtet
beispielsweise auch über google das mit
hilfe einer software depressionen heilen
und herzinfarkte mit hilfe künstlicher
nano-partikel voraussagen will
forschungsgruppen aus der biotechnik und
medizin erhalten in naher zukunft eine
verlängerung der menschlichen
lebensspanne auf 150 jahre für
realistisch im besten fall eine zeit in
der wir gesund leben können also in
gewisser weise vital sind dennoch ist
auch hier ganz klar selbst wenn die
wissenschaft in der lage ist und
biologisch für eine längere zeit jung zu
halten gilt das nicht gleichzeitig auch
für unsere geistige jugend denn wie will
man es verhindern dass unser geist
erfahrung sammelt die welt kennen lernt
und sich so weiterentwickelt und in
diesem sinne eben auch alter
philosophen diskutieren sogar darüber ob
irgendwann der zeitpunkt gekommen ist an
dem der menschliche geist soweit
gealtert ist dass der dazugehörige
mensch gar nicht mehr unbedingt
weiterleben möchte
auf der anderen seite wäre 150 jahre
langes leben natürlich eine große chance
für den einzelnen menschen stellt euch
mal vor man könnte in ruhe eine
ausbildung machen oder studieren dann 20
jahre lang beispielsweise als pilot
durch die welt fliegen um dann nochmal
ein architekturstudium dranzuhängen
zum schluss stünde dann noch eine
karriere als sänger oder sängerin offen
denn zeit um sich selbst zu
verwirklichen wäre genug noch menschen
die 150 jahre alt werden können hätten
fatale konsequenzen bezüglich der
überbevölkerung und der sozialen
ungerechtigkeit denn schon jetzt
existieren zu viele menschen auf der
erde
und auch jetzt schon gibt es maßnahmen
die das verhindern sollen china ist
lange mit der sogenannten
ein-kind-politik gefahren solche
maßnahmen müssten dann ja verschärft
werden
doch vorher steht eine wichtige debatte
an was ist uns mehr wert die freiheit
für jeden einzelnen von uns sich sofort
zu pflanzen wer möchte oder aber die
möglichkeit seine eigene lebensspanne
signifikant auszuweiten
ihr seht also das ganze macht dringend
auch ethische diskussionen notwendig und
da ist dann auch eine philosophische
frage zu stellen nur weil es demnächst
wissenschaftlich und medizinisch möglich
sein wird 150 jahre alt zu werden sollen
wir menschen das eigentlich voll denn
sicher ist teure therapien um das leben
zu verlängern könnten sich zumindest
anfangs nur reiche leute leisten
diejenigen also die auch schon in vielen
anderen bereichen des lebens
privilegiert sind und sie hätten ganz
andere interessen als menschen mit einer
kurzen lebensspanne
das würde wiederum eine
zweiklassengesellschaft verschärfen
bevor also solche medizinischen
möglichkeiten zur verfügung stehen muss
schon im voraus blickt vieles beachtet
und diskutiert werden wenn er als erstes
neues zum thema uralt werden und zu
allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
endet meine telefonnummer hierbei
whatsapp wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr euch
auch mit mir über telegramm instagram
oder den facebook messenger verknüpfen
dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen
anderen vom neuesten video täglich
andy kann dort direkt über mich in der
redaktion von links und mitmachen und
mitbestimmen was hier praktisch schon
passiert der direkte draht zu mir und zu
beginn gibt es auch noch ein kleines
goodie einfach hier draufklicken und
natürlich nicht das aber mit der genau
glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter
mit dafür auch draufklicken ist der tod
tödlich oder leben wir weiter ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran